I'm Uta Francke, I'm a human geneticist
originally from Germany, as you can hear.
And I'm an Emeritus Professor here at
Stanford and also senior medical director at 23andMe.
>> So when people talk about variation in the human genome, we oftentimes.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Talk about single nucleotide variance, which we'll come to in, in later
lessons for, for our course. is that the main kind of variation that exists
in the human genome, are these single letter differences? Or
are there other kinds of variation that are important too?
>> We have identified about 15 million single additive differences. So by
sheer number, they're the most common. But then there are other variants there
called copy number variations. But whole chunks of the genome can be
repeated, and they can be present in these, two or three or many copies.
And there are differences between human beings,
well some people have two copies, some have
five, some may have 12. And if you look at the total number of nucleoids
[INAUDIBLE]
than those, then this is more common. So the individual copy number variance, or
CNVs, are fewer than the ones that we have identified for SNVs. But,
if you look at the amount of genomic sequence, and what, in this
type of, what's called structural variation, it
involves the larger part of a genome.
>> I see, so, between single nucleotide variance and copy number
variation those are the two main kinds, or,
the two main forms of variation in humans.
>> Yeah, then there are others, like inversions, where certain pieces of
the genome can be turned around in some people, and not in others.
>> And even, translocations? How viable are translocations, and do they get
propagated at all in a population over time, or most translocations inviable?
>> Well
we find them in families, you know, there are
balanced translocations where a piece of a chromosome is taken
off and hooked somewhere else, or two pieces have
been exchanged. And as long as they are balanced, meaning
that the right number of genes is there, people
are fine. They would know about it. Unless a break
is in a gene, but that's pretty unusual. A
break is most often in a repetitive sequence. But then,
when these people may have children, because
of what happens in meiosis, that the
chromosomes align and cross over. It's possible
that a child inherits a chromosome that only
has an extra copy and is then, gets the other one that's missing something. Then
you have an unbalanced translocation and that
can cause very bad developmental defects intellectual deficits.
These are the children who we see in the clinic
and we look at their chromosomes. And look at their parents
and we see that translocation has been passed on to
several generations already. But otherwise, they don't last in, in populations.